there's this trick that we all do to get  through our day we take a box and into  that box we place all the horrors of the  world and we close the box and pretend  it doesn't exist  only some of us we've lost our ability  to pretend we're looking for a special  operator like you for a while who are  you  we do the dirty work others can't here's  the fun part now on you're dead it's all  erased by more criminal records no more  getting arrested just for being naked or  just usual stuff you know being naked  getting drunk casual stuff so we're all  gonna die we blend in to disappear watch  me  this man honestly I didn't think we'd  make it this far  [Music]  [Music]  was wrong Hey  we're all gonna die  may as well do it while we're alive  [Music]  sounds fun right  [Applause]  you  you